charles michel macky sall à emmanuel
macron vienne viennent d'arriver la
conférence de presse à commence on
n'écoute que tu te le président français
le président du conseil européen
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les ambassadeurs
mesdames et messieurs merci d'être là
nous retrouvons donc dans quelques
heures à bruxelles pour le sommet entre
l'union africaine et l'union européenne
mais nous avons
réuni hier soir à paris l'ensemble des
partenaires africains européens
canadiens impliqués à nos côtés dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
cette concertation était précédé par
d'intenses échanges depuis plusieurs
mois tant au niveau politique
opérationnelle et elle a débouché sur
des décisions importantes
qui sont retranscrites dans un
communiqué conjoint sorti il ya quelques
minutes mais dont je souhaite ici aussi
vous rendre compte
à l'heure où d'autres menaces
stratégiques pèse sur la sécurité du
continent européen et mobilise à juste
titre nos attentions diplomatique il
était tout d'abord important d'adresser
un message de continuité
sur notre engagement dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel
l'europe est un partenaire de confiance
qui s'engagent dans la durée aux côtés
de ses alliés
pour faire face à des menaces qui
s'inscrivent dans un temps long et elle
est aux côtés de la cedeao de l'union
africaine du g5 c'est
la menace à laquelle les pays du sahel
et de la région sont confrontés à un nom
al qaïda et des ch
ces deux organisations terroristes ont
choisi de faire de l'afrique du sel en
particulier maintenant de manière
croissante
golfe de guinée une priorité de leur
stratégie d'expansion
elles investissent et instrumentalise
pour cela des causes locales afin de
mieux poursuivre un agenda global et
régional
cela justifie que nous restions engagés
dans la durée dans cette région et nous
sommes bien placés ayant affronté ces
organisations sur notre propre
territoire et dans d'autres géographe
pour savoir que cela implique de la
constance et de la ténacité
depuis 2013 et la décision courageuse du
président françois hollande d'intervenir
au mali à la demande des autorités
maliennes et des autorités de la région
la france a joué un rôle fédérateur de
cette mobilisation internationale en
faveur du sahel où ce sont désormais
près de 25 mille hommes qui sont
déployés au titre des différentes
missions internationales
les décisions que nous avons prises au
sommet de pau en janvier 2020 puis à
n'djamena en février 2021 ont permis
d'amplifier encore cette dynamique et
d'agir désormais dans le cadre d'une
coalition pour le sahel
nous continuerons c'est ce que j'ai dit
hier à mes interlocuteurs à assurer ce
rôle fédérateur
et là où une dimension militaire est
nécessaire
le rôle de nation cadre
au delà du maintien de notre engagement
ces échanges ont aussi dégagé un
consensus pour faire évoluer les
modalités de notre action au sahel ceci
dans quatre directions la première en
impliquant et en appuyant davantage les
pays voisins de la bande sahélienne à
savoir les pays du golfe de guinée
comme l'ont démontré les attaques menées
il ya quelques jours dans le nord du
bénin
ces états sont de plus en plus exposés à
des tentatives d'implantation des
groupes terroristes sur leur territoire
si le g5 celle demeure une enceinte
incontournable pour coordonner les
efforts à l'échelle de la bande
sahélienne
l'initiative d'accra qui rassemble le
burkina faso la côte d'ivoire le ghana
le togo le bénin doit aussi devenir un
cadre de référence
non pas pour créer de nouvelles
structures régionales mais pour veiller
à ce que chaque état fasse sa part des
efforts et reçoivent des partenaires le
soutien bilatéral dont il a besoin
les groupes terroristes se joue en effet
de la porosité des frontières et une
coordination transfrontalière est
indispensable pour contrer cette
stratégie c'est tout le sens d'un
renforcement de la coordination entre
les pays de la région et c'est pourquoi
j'ai cinq ça l initiative d'accra
largement la cedeao et tous les pays qui
étaient impliqués ce que je viens de
citer ainsi que le sénégal sont clé dans
cette lutte contre le terrorisme la
seconde évolution la deuxième évolution
sur laquelle nous nous sommes accordés
est de mettre davantage les populations
civiles au coeur de notre stratégie de
lutte contre les groupes terroristes
les populations sahéliennes et de toute
la région sont la première cible des
exactions d'al qaïda et de dèche elles
ne peuvent pas pour autant être réduite
à un rôle de victime elles sont aussi le
premier rempart contre ces groupes à
condition que par un sursaut civile nous
soyons davantage à leurs côtés pas
seulement par le prisme trop étroit de
la sécurité
l'alliance pour le sahel lancé en 2017 a
justement pour objectif d'appuyer les
populations mais aussi sans s'y
substituer les volontés locales
elle réunit à ce jour plus de 25
partenaires dont bientôt les etats-unis
22 milliards d'engagements financiers
ont été pris dans ce cadre et plusieurs
milliers de projets je souhaite que
cette alliance et c'est l'orientation
que nous avons collectivement retenu
soit l'outil pour accélérer ce
changement de paradigme
déployées d'abord des programmes civils
et sociaux selon les besoins exprimés
par les acteurs régionaux qui viendront
prévenir l'expansion des groupes
terroristes et consolider les stratégies
des autorités nationales
ce n'est qu'en complément de cet effort
préalable qu'une action militaire peu
lorsqu'elle est nécessaire produire son
efficacité
troisième élément en cohérence avec
cette orientation nous nous sommes
accordés sur l'impératif de faire
évoluer les modalités de notre présence
militaire
au sahel comme dans le golfe de guinée
les attentes de nos partenaires ont
évolué et la sensibilité des opinions
publiques des pays de la région a elle
aussi changé
nous devons en tirer les conséquences et
accélérer la transformation que nous
avions engagés au sommet de pau en
janvier 2020 puis accéléré il ya un an à
l'issue du sommet de n'djamena
notre empreinte doit se réduire comme
nous l'avons fait au nord du mali en
fermant trois de nos emprises à kidal
tessalit et tombouctou il s'agit de nous
recentrer sur demande de nos partenaires
là où notre contribution est attendue
toujours en soutien et encore davantage
intégrés comme nous le sommes au niger
avec les forces armées de la région
nous définirons dans les semaines et
mois qui viennent
l'appui que nous apporterons à chacun
des pays de la région sur la base des
besoins qui seront exprimés
s'est appuyé pour inclure de l'aide en
matière de formation et d'entraînement
de la fourniture d'équipements voir un
appui à leurs opérations contre le
terrorisme
enfin et c'est le quatrième axe nous
sommes rejoints sur une évidence
nous ne pouvons pas rester engagés
militairement aux côtés d' autorité de
fait dont nous ne partageons ni la
stratégie ni les objectifs cachés c'est
la situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui au mali la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne peut pas tout
justifier
elle ne doit pas sous prétexte d'être
une priorité absolue se transformer en
exercice de conservation indéfinie du
pouvoir elle ne peut pas non plus
justifier une escalade de la violence
par le recours à des mercenaires dans
les exactions sont documentés en
république centrafricaine et dont
l'exercice de la force mais encadrées
par aucune règle ni par aucune
convention
dans ces conditions la france et ses
partenaires engagés dans des missions de
lutte contre le terrorisme à savoir les
états participant à la task force
takouba ont pris la décision de retirer
leur présence militaire au mali
ce retrait se traduira par la fermeture
des emprises de gossip de ménaka et de
gao il sera effectuée de manière
ordonnée avec les forces armées
maliennes et avec la mission des nations
unies au mali
durant cette période nous maintiendrons
nos missions de soutien au profit de la
minus mans
s'agissant de l'engagement de nos
partenaires européens il sera maintenu
et s'intégrera dans l'art et
articulations de ce dispositif
avec l'accord des autorités nigériennes
des éléments européens seront
repositionnées
côté des forces armées nigériennes dans
la région frontalière du mali
enfin notre engagement aux côtés des
populations maliennes sera préservée au
travers des programmes de l'alliance
pour le sahel sous réserve que ces
programmes ne puisse être détourné pour
financer des activités de mercenaires ou
le terrorisme lui même
au final au travers de ces évolutions
nous accélérons un mouvement collectif
qui avait déjà été amorcée à pau puis à
djamena le modèle d'intervention que
nous avons bâti est menée depuis 2013 a
permis d'obtenir des résultats
considérables la france et ces personnes
et ses partenaires ont infligé à
al-qaïda et est des défaites qui ont
changé la nature et la capacité de
projection de ces deux organisations
ces résultats ont été obtenus dans le
cadre d'une fraternité d'armes nous et
dans la libération de la france et 50
ans plus tard dans la libération du mali
la france n'oublie aucun épisode
elle n'oublie aucun de ses 53 53 soldats
aucun de ces blessés et de leurs
familles qui se sont sacrifiés pour
cette cause et pour nos deux pays et en
m'adressant à vous ce matin j'ai une
pensée pour l'ensemble de nos soldats
tombés au sahel pour la liberté
pour l'ensemble de nos blessés et pour
leurs familles de même que j'ai une
pensée pour les six français qui ont
perdu la vie au niger en août 2020
fauché avec leurs accompagnateurs
nigériens alors qu'ils étaient venus
s'engager avec l'organisation acte aide
au moment où nous nous adversaires se
réinventer modifier leur stratégie
l'erreur aurait été de demeurer
statiques ou de nous égarer dans des
combats qui ne relèvent pas de la lutte
contre les organisations terroristes
nous jetons donc là les bases d'un
engagement renouvelé qui permettra aux
européens à la france de continuer à
jouer leur rôle d'appui de soutien
d'entraînement en un mot de partenaires
c'est ce modèle de partenariat
respectueux équilibré que nous allons
consacrer et étendre à d'autres domaines
dans le cadre du sommet union africaine
union européenne qui s'ouvrira dans
quelques heures à bruxelles je vais
maintenant céder la parole au président
macky sall président en exercice aussi
de l'union africaine merci beaucoup
monsieur le président cher manuel
bonjour à tous
merci pour cet aimable invitation
et pour l'accueil convivial je salue la
présence parmi nous du président nana
akufo addo pris dans la république du
ghana et président en exercice de la
cedeao mais également la présence de mon
ami charles michel président du conseil
européen
ma qualité de président en exercice
lignes africaines je suis venu hier à
paris à l'invitation du club de mâcon
avec un certain nombre de nos collègues
africains et européens
pour ainsi que le prix dans la
commission de l'union africaine pour
poursuivre nos consultations
et je dois dire que ces consultations en
prélude de au sommet qui se tiendra tout
à l'heure à bruxelles ont débuté déjà
lors de la réunion du g20 à rome et se
sont poursuivis au forum de dakar pour
la paix et la sécurité et le mois
dernier à bruxelles que yeves c'était
vraiment la dernière réunion de réglages
et ici à paris nous avons surtout
échangé hier nuit comme l'a dit le
président mâcon sur le sujet la sécurité
la lutte contre le terrorisme
et c'est une question vitale pour nos
deux continents et une question
d'intérêt comment puisque 15 km à peine
sait pas l'afrique l'europe donc tout ce
qui touche la touche également l'autre
et vice versa la lutte contre le
terrorisme et de voeux depuis plus d'une
décennie
un défi majeur pour l'afrique et nous ne
voulons pas que le continent devienne le
ventre mou du terrorisme international
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons ardemment
pour suivre nos partenaires européens
les efforts solidaire déjà engagé de
longue date que nous avons toujours
salués en particulier la présence
française au mali est le plus dans la
rappeler la demande des autorités
maliennes déjà depuis 2013 sous
différentes opérations serval par cannes
ainsi que la présence européenne
et nous avons retenu hier avec nos
partenaires que
considérant les situations nouvelles au
mali nous comprenons cette décision
prise par les autorités européennes
françaises de ne pas
poursuivre leur intervention sur le
théâtre malien compte tenu des
situations nées un peu de coups d'état
et des difficultés qu'il ya entre que
malienne et autorités européennes sur
les opérations en cours alors nous en
avons pris acte mais surtout nous avons
convenu avec l'europe que la lutte conte
le sel contre le terrorisme au sahel ne
serait être la seule à faire depuis
africains et là dessus sans consensus et
c'est heureux que un engagement a été
renouvelée de rester dans la région et
de l'hercule et le dispositif
nous espérons simplement que les
discussions en tout cas entre la cedeao
et le mali permettront d'arriver à un
taux normal à des institutions civiles
issues d'élections de façon à pouvoir
reprendre le cours normal des choses
je voudrais dire par ailleurs que
en ce qui concerne la cedeao elle a
appliqué rigoureusement ses textes après
avoir accompagné les autorités de
transition et lorsque nous avons été
devant l'impossibilité de trouver un
consensus sur une date raisonnable pour
la tenue d'élections évidemment le la
traditionnelle portant sur
la bonne gouvernance la démocratie a été
appliquée mais nous continuons les
échanges il me semble que deere que
lundi prochain nous allons à nouveau une
nouvelle réunion entre la cedeao l'union
africaine et les autorités maliennes et
nous verrons la suite qui sera donnée
dans le cadre des relations de la cedeao
et l'union africaine
et surtout le mali et je voudrais dire
que nous avons quand même salué les
efforts de la france les sacrifices
également et c'est aussi l'occasion pour
nous incliner devant la mémoire des
soldats tombés au champ d'honneur au
sahel pour lutter contre le terrorisme
et nous avons salué également la
position de toute l'europe qui a été
réaffirmée y est de continuer sa
présence en afrique et au sahel
pour lutter contre le terrorisme parce
que ça ne saurait être une libre qui
serait laissée au seul africain c'est
une globale et je crois que c'est le
plus important maintenant nous allons
tout faire pour que la situation
revienne à la normale à ce que je
voulais dire on remercie encore une fois
pour cette position
cette année qu'on voulait rester en
afrique